he's Tom Verducci the Sports Illustrated
senior writer Fox and baseball Network
analyst he joins us where are you today
Tom at Citi Field there's no game today
though I just found out there's no is
there a press conference there what are
you doing at Citi Field no there's
actually a Baseball Writers Association
meeting oh that's a TV show I don't know
why we don't have cameras on that but
yeah does it ever get ugly oh yeah
that's why we should have cameras it's
good TV
yeah it's people let it all hang out
well wait what are you arguing over well
everybody's cranky after the postseason
we're all on short sleep right for a
month I've just knock-down-drag-out
games going til 3:00 in the morning so
we have these postseason awards that we
give out besides the major awards the
national award the New York Chapter has
their own awards there's a lot of
arguing about who deserves what it's all
sleep deprivation is to grom getting
your pitching award that's me he would
then I I know people look at the one
loss record and say that's not a say
young winner but the award goes to the
best pitcher and the league period and I
defy anybody to come up with a good
argument on how it's anybody else but
degrom all right that leads me to
Clayton Kershaw's afternoon the deadline
was extended by both sides here for the
opportunity for him to opt out what do
you think
Clayton Kershaw will do and should do I
think the Dodgers are going to extend
his contract you got two years and 65
million left on the contract now he's
not going to get that average annual
value from the Dodgers or anybody else
down the road here but this is pretty
much his chance to use leverage for
probably the last time you think about
where his leverage might be two years
from now the way his stuff is trending
down he won't have a lot of leverage
then so you know the Yankees did this
with Sabathia in 2011 they added one
year and 30 million to his contract he's
not going to get that kind of dollars
Sabathia is coming off a better year in
11 than Kershaw is 18 well listen
Clayton's an institution is an icon with
the Dodgers he's still an effective
pitcher he's not in a
Fitzer in terms of stuff but he can
still win games for you the back is
certainly an issue I don't think with
his stuff right now Dan he should be
thinking about going to the American
League I know the Texas Rangers have
been floated as a possibility I think
they worked this thing out and you know
just kind of play with the years and
added dollars here as an extension
rather than you know a full-blown brand
new contract
what about Manny Machado future don't
think he's going back to the Dodgers I
think he did cost himself some money
here with the postseason just the way he
responded you know admitting that he
doesn't hustle you know striking people
at first base unnecessarily not running
out balls a whole laundry list here's
what one manager told me Dan that
Machado is going to get paid I think we
all know that but he might have cost
himself years because when you think
about a 10-year deal that's what we've
seen for somebody in their mid 20s you
know a great player like Machado you're
making that guy your franchise player
that means you're invested in a guy for
a 10-year period where he's going to
influence all the younger players in
your organization be the face of your
franchise I think this postseason gave
something maybe many teams pause about
whether they want to make Manny Machado
that kind of franchise player take them
for next three or four years at just
incredible dollars you know 35 million
to 40 million yeah I think teams might
be willing to debt do that but I think
that long-term investment is going to
scare a lot of people what about Dave
Roberts future with the Dodgers is he
safe I think he's safe I had heard that
they were working on an extension even
before the postseason began listen
that's a tough team to manage right yeah
I mean you have the influences from
above and below above you have very
analytically employment inclined for an
office a lot of people there would
experience very hands-on and below you
have a very tough clubhouse whether it's
you know the platoon system that they
run we're trying to get every day
players
part-time roles and keep them happy and
productive or some of the personalities
you know if we get Peterson a Machado
it's a difficult group I thought he did
a really good job you know listen three
straight years he's been to the at least
the NLCS twice the World Series I think
he's going to come back
then listen a lot of people got on him
in the in the postseason for his
managing moves I mean we do that anyway
right the games are Soho profile but I
think he did a good job with the bullpen
uses the problem for me is the Dodgers
didn't hit and that made every pitching
move critical that he made when it
didn't work out they didn't just didn't
hit enough to withstand up one move that
didn't work out
does Bryce Harper knows know where he's
playing next year no I don't it
I do think Bryce in a perfect world with
lots to go back to Washington you know
the only organization he's known he's
been what 17 18 years old is definitely
a comfort level there they've been
competitive haven't gotten has the first
round but no I would say the answer to
your question though Dan is probably
he's going to go to the team that offers
him the most money I truly believe that
I think this is all about a bidding war
I think he wants to get at least a
dollar more than Giancarlo Stanton to
have the longest contract given to an
everyday player and who that team is
right now I don't know but I think that
will drive the decision more than any
kind of feeling for the Washington
Nationals wait you know I look at Bryce
Harper and I know that you had the cover
story on him when he was what 17 16
years old yeah how does he handle the
pressure so 16 you're on the cover of
Sports Illustrated and you're the LeBron
James of baseball and now does he want
that title of the highest-paid player in
baseball does he want the added pressure
that goes along with it how does he
handle it yeah I think he does I'll
never forget writing that story now when
I reported this story of when he was 16
I didn't know it was going to be the
cover but then when I found out that it
was at first I was like what is a pretty
big ask to put a high school kid on the
cover of Si well I came away thinking
man this is a one kid he was a kid at
the time who can handle that
I think he's grown up with the spotlight
on him I think he enjoys it I don't
think there's any extra added pressure
if he's got a huge contract I think he
needs to learn how to win that's the
biggest thing I think he needs to be in
a culture where winning is the top
priority I think it would help if there
was another star player on the
team or he just didn't have to be the
guy that to leave a team entirely in
terms of being you know it's a clubhouse
leader I think getting in the right
atmosphere is gonna help him win but in
terms of pressure my goodness yeah got
to live up to a contract I don't see
that being an issue with this guy I know
we've seen man the past with a lot of
guys I think he's cut from a different
cloth
how much did how different is he then
Mike Trout when it comes to that no were
easy no I think he is different I think
you know I think Mike's a little bit
different in terms of just the attention
that he seeks or is comfortable with
I think price like I said you know
remember Dan when he was 12 or 13 these
travel teams were flying him into
tournaments to be let's face it kind of
a ringer you add somebody to your travel
team roster for some big tournament he's
been a hired gun he's been the guy that
everybody's had their eyes on Mike
didn't grow up that way
so I think it's a different atmosphere I
always say that that brace is kind of
the epitome of what is now the travel
player generation where you play more
for yourself and your skills and to be
seen then you do for winning games you
know when we grew up it was about
playing for your high school team or
your Legion team or your local little
league team those barriers are all gone
now now it's you just hired guns that's
about showcase atmospheres where it's
about your own individual ability I'm
not saying it's a bad thing when Brice
is the epitome that new generation I
play nice today at Citi Field there ton
thank you Tom Tom Verducci Sports
Illustrated senior writer also works for
a Fox and Major League Baseball network
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]